failed former president Donald Trump's
criminal nightmare in Georgia is looking
very real writes Greg Walters for vice
Fulton County district attorney fani
Willis says decisions are imminent in
her investigation of Trump's attempts to
reverse his 2020 defeat in Georgia
remember this is the one where Trump
said I need 11 000 votes give me a break
um Walters writes where is Trump's most
pressing criminal investigation there's
little doubt now it is in Georgia it is
in Georgia Trump may now be just weeks
or even days away from learning whether
he will be criminally charged for
election meddling in the state according
to comments made by the local prosecutor
that prosecutor is D.A Fanny Willis who
said those decisions are imminent and
that the report on what the grand jury
found should stay secret for now in
order to protect the Integrity of future
prosecutions of multiple people quote we
are asking that the report not be
released because you you having seen the
rep that report decisions are imminent
we have to be mindful of protecting
future defendants rights do I believe
Trump is going to be indicted in Georgia
well I will tell you in a moment I do
want to mention that our sponsor for
this segment is Masterworks it's been an
up and down year for investors to say
the least retail investors down 30
percent last year the typical 60 40
portfolio down 15 to 25 percent it's
rough it has been rough I believe that
an expansion of portfolios to include
alternative assets is interesting many
of these alternative assets outperform
traditional Assets in 2022 Blue Chip art
had a record-breaking year and it wasn't
just last year contemporary art has
actually outperformed the S P 500 Total
return for the past 26 years and art is
lowly correlated to stocks and bonds
which means even if stocks and bonds are
down art can do okay if you want to get
in Masterworks is the place to do it
they sold Nine Paintings last year all
at a profit the last three sales
returned 10 13 and 35 percent net
Masterworks acquires Blue Chip art by
world-renowned artists like Picasso
Banksy Warhol they qualify the paintings
with the the SEC which I've linked below
and you can just invest a fraction of
each painting and if Masterworks sells
it at a profit you get a slice of that
return there's a waiting list to sign up
you can skip the line at
masterworks.art Pacman you can use the
link down below Will trump be indicted
in the state of Georgia
you know
I hate that this is where we are
but if I had to bet
I don't think he's getting indicted I
hope Trump gets indicted I believe he
should be indicted based on the facts
and the evidence but I don't know that
anyone has the willingness
audacity commitment to the hell that
will rain down upon them and likely
their families if they are the first to
indict Trump I hope that I'm wrong I
hope that fonnie Willis does it and that
we learn about it today tomorrow next
week sooner sooner the better but if I
were a betting man and I'm not
I don't know that we're going to see
that happen and there are many places
where Trump could get indicted there's
the federal investigation that was
referred to the doj by the January 6th
committee there is the southern district
of New York investigation there is the
Georgia investigation
I believe you can make the legal case
that indictment is Justified in all
three and probably more
Trump also facing defamation suits and
all sorts of things but I worry and I
really hope that I'm wrong that nobody
is going to go and do it now if Trump
does get indicted what does it do to his
2024 campaign in some strange way
it may give Trump an out from a campaign
that maybe is doomed to fail I don't
know right now whether Trump is likely
to be the Republican nominee or not
there are polls that look fine polls
that look problematic struggles that
Trump is having to find leaders for
example in South Carolina willing to be
up on the stage with him I don't know
where it's going to go but there is
speculation that Trump will want a way
out if it doesn't seem like things are
looking good by the start of 2024. one
way out would be I've got a health issue
the other possible way out would be I am
so encumbered by these witch-hunt
indictments of me that I have no choice
but to abandon the campaign and focus
fully and solely on my defense in some
strange way it may end up giving Trump
an out from an election he could
ultimately lose but it's too early to
say for sure for now we remain on
indictment watch from the doj from the
southern district of New York and of
course from Georgia as well